joining us once again on the program the
vaccines minister nadeem zahari mr zowie
always good to have you on and
as always a very busy day very busy week
for you and the rest of the government
clearly everyone is very keen to
discover how and
when we might be exiting lockdown and
and at the core of all of that are the
the four tests that the prime minister
is deploying run us through those
good morning everyone yes of course so
it will be
first of all the vaccine program
continuing uh at pace so we will
offer the vaccine to the over 50s by the
middle of april
and all of the adult population by the
end of
july the second is that the vaccines are
working and that we're seeing a
reduction in infection
hospitalization of course death uh the
third
of which is that infection rates
are not rising because of the different
uh parts of the opening up of the
economy to a level which would
overwhelm the nhs and of course in terms
of hospitalization
and the fourth is variance i.e that we
are
managing to keep uh variants under
control
and that we're not seeing what we saw
sadly
uh just before christmas which is the
new variant becoming more infectious and
the dominant variant
in the country and leading to the
large-scale hospitalization that we saw
in uh december january and of course
even now
so they are the four tests it is uh
making sure that
we proceed at each step and are able to
assess and then flex uh accordingly but
you'll hear more from the prime minister
both in the commons when he presents the
roadmap but also tonight in the press
conference
sure and there will be parents the
length and breadth of england
uh looking enviously at the date of
march the eighth
for all the schools to reopen however
just in terms of the four tests
that you've outlined the second of those
the evidence showing that vaccines are
reducing hospitalizations
and deaths in those vaccinated do we yet
have that evidence do we yet have that
information
certainly not in the public domain by my
reading so
the prime minister will say more about
this but you will know that public
health england have been running a
couple of large-scale studies
uh the siren study which tests the
frontline
health care staff who were in group two
if you recall of the vaccination program
so very early on
and uh another study called the valdi
which has been testing
care home residents again they were
group one and of course the other
evidence but uh the prime minister will
be saying more about that
uh suffice to say the evidence looks
good the oxford team
demonstrated their own evidence of uh
cutting transmission by
uh two thirds and of course um you know
we are
um we wouldn't be in this place this
morning to be able to say that we're
going to reopen schools on the
8th of march and of course as the school
holidays begin on the 29th of march
we will look at the rule of six and two
families being
to um uh see each other outdoors
if we haven't you know if we're not
confident that actually the vaccine
program is beginning to really
uh bear fruit sure can we just be
absolutely clear though with with all
schools reopening on
on march the 8th the expectation has to
be
that the number of infections will
increase
so that that as i say to you at the
beginning
all of that goes into the gradual
cautious reopening of schools and then
gradually reopening the rest of the
economy
as we vaccinate more people it is not a
coincidence
that the 8th of march is the date that
we have focused on because
if you take the mid-april date where we
will have
given at least one dose to all
over 50s offered that one dose
protection to all
over 50s if you go three weeks after the
middle of april that takes you to the
first week
of march now that phase one is 99
of mortality so it's no coincidence that
we are
uh opening schools after three weeks of
uh protecting
the over 50s and that phase one and then
we'll carry on
i get that sorry sorry to interrupt
minister the the reason is
we have had for for a few days now in
fact and from yourself and on the
program last week that the way out of
this is to be incredibly
cautious is to open things gradually i
mean the one aspect of the road map in
which
it doesn't feel particularly gradual is
getting kids back into schools you look
at what wales you look at scotland
they're going
in a phased return to school so they can
look at the data
see what happens in schools as as
children go back
why are we not doing that because it
doesn't feel cautious it feels somewhat
in congress actually
to reopen all the schools on one day and
say that this is a cautious approach
well i would say to you it's actually
quite the opposite if you look at
where hospitalization and of course
death
has uh come from with this pandemic it
is from
that one to nine group all the way from
the over 80s
the those obviously um that are
clinically extremely vulnerable but then
also
the uh over 50. so we're waiting
until all of that group the over 50s
have got the protection
i.e three weeks after getting the first
dose
before we reopen schools and of course
we do know that
uh infection around amongst children is
very very
and so this is a cautious
slow and deliberate reopening
uh as we continue of course to assess
the uh four tests that you and i have
just described to your viewers
i i i understand that that certainly
some of the evidence that
suggests that transmissibility amongst
children is it it's not as much of an
issue as it is amongst you know yourself
or myself but
you only need to look at for example i
mean there are examples of this all
around the world the situation in
british columbia and canada at a moment
where the
the kent variant is right running havoc
through the school system there a number
of schools having to have temporary
closures
look we understand that the plan as
outlined by the government is that we
don't roll back once
something is relaxed that is the way of
it but you have to say that
there could well be a big pause in this
roadmap
coming as we look at the data that
emerges from the school system
so so hence why the the fourth test if
you go back to your first question
um the dominant variant in the uk is the
one that you
refer to as the uh ken varian the
vaccines
very high efficacy against the dominant
variant which is why we're confident
on the vaccine effectiveness
the vaccine rollout continues to be uh
you know
going to plan we've in fact brought it
forward
more ambitious by mid april to offer the
vaccine to
over 50 year olds all over 50 year olds
but there is
a a you know a butt in there which is to
say
we have to make sure that infection
rates and hospitalization
also remain under control which is the
third test and the fourth test
back to your canadian example is that we
keep control
uh on variance and make sure that we
have that
ability to sequence which we have genome
sequence
largest one of the largest in the world
we account for about 50 of all
sequencing of covert
muted mutations and of course
surge testing and isolation as we've
been doing
uh with the variants that we've
discovered from south africa for example
and make sure we keep that under review
and control
so it is cautious we have to be careful
we want it to be sustainable as you
quite rightly described
and can we talk about the the second key
date in all of this march the 29th
which which you've already mentioned of
course the the suggestion is that might
be the point that we see the end to
stay at home indeed at the end to stay
local
plenty people up and down the country
myself included will be wondering
if that is the point at which those of
us who live
some distance from our families might be
able to go and see them
outside of course you're not allowed
indoors it is your reading of the the
relaxation that
people can travel at a distance to see
their family
uh on march the 29th if everything goes
well
quite right if everything goes well uh
this is outdoor
versus indoor we know there is a plenty
about to suggest that
outdoor the transmission is much lower
it is allowing two families to be able
to uh come together outdoors or the rule
of six
and it is a national um rule rather than
a regional or tiered uh rules so
um i think the important thing is to
wait to
hear from the prime minister this
afternoon in parliament but also
this evening on the details sure sure
but i i will push a little bit on this
and my producer working with me this
morning he lives in leeds it might be
possible for him
to get home and come back in a day
whereas
for me to go home and see my family
would potentially involve an
overnight stay in scotland of the two
are either of those in your mind either
not possible not permitted or not
advisable
so as long as it's outdoors and it is
two families or the rule of six
uh then that is what will be committed
if the
four tests continue uh to uh be
delivered
upon then that will be the national
um lockdown of course scotland uh as you
mentioned
and uh northern ireland and wales will
be setting out their own
um road map towards
reopening uh their uh economies
as well so at the moment uh the focus is
very much
on you know steady as she goes outdoor
versus indoor priority being uh children
in schools
second priority is obviously allowing
two people on the 8th of march to meet
outside for a coffee uh uh to sort of
address some of the issues
around loneliness and of course mental
health as well
and then the 29th is two families or
rule of six coming together and outdoor
sports
activities as well tennis can we then
sorry minister can we then just just be
absolutely candid
even on the roadmap as i understand it
even in the best case scenario
pubs restaurants non-essential shops
hairdressers
beauty treatments and the like none of
that will be happening even in the best
case scenario
until the other side of easter well i
however much tempting it may be neil i
will not preempt my prime minister
before he
stands up uh in the chamber the dispatch
box and
describes the road map to
parliamentarians into the country and of
course
at the press conference tonight i think
uh it's important that
uh yeah we we do this cautiously
steadily
based on the vaccination out which has
been you know i think
you know in many ways one of the great
achievements
of the coming together the nhs armed
forces the volunteers
the doctors nurses the private sector
that delivered
the vaccine both in terms of the
scientists and the manufacturers but
also they're delivering now for us in
the deployment
with the distribution so a lot of
hard work has gone in and we don't want
this hard-won
uh you know achievement
to be in some way jeopardized by uh
us you know emotionally feeling that
we've got to try and go faster we've got
to be
led later not the date very very quickly
because i know you have to go
can you offer a cast iron set in stone
guarantee that there will never be
another national lockdown
i think the important thing is to make
it sustainable you're absolutely right
without the prime minister if i look at
my own portfolio
has tasked us not only to deliver the
the largest vaccination program in the
history
of the nhs of this country but also to
look at
variant vaccines that may be needed
as an autumn booster if we need it
and of course a longer term uh future
proofing of the vaccination program so
i'm confident that if we do this
cautiously
and we do it based on the data the
evidence then it will be sustainable
and it should be the last time we ever
enter the severe
level of lockdown because of covert 19.